la loi réserve bien des surprises
le mystère se trouve quelquefois de
l'autre côté de la rive entre tours et
digoin une étrange créature a monopolisé
une belle équipe
le temps d'une petite enquête ligérienne
parfois c'est juste ça la loire une
succession d'image aussi fugace cas
miroitement matière insaisissable a
coulé en une comme de l'eau c'est beau
ça ne fait pas l'histoire les histoires
elles se nourrissent d'exception et
alors là branle bas de combat
c'est pas souvent qu'on vous appelle
pour ce genre de choses non ça reste
rare en policiers pompiers plongeurs
on a sorti le grand jeu pour le
mystérieux visite
et maintenant une cage qui a dû voir
passer plus souvent des chiens que que
quoi d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui peut être à la fois sous
l'eau sur l'eau est suffisamment
exotique pour attirer autant de monde
un crocodile non rassurez-vous ce
jour-là al arich près de tours
c'était bien un chien mais un chien de
mer autant dire un phoque
un phoque veau marin c'est un et mal
connues comme marin et mais qui peut
faire des très grands déplacements en
période de reproduction
il veut groupe et ils se reproduisent
sur des bancs de sable en baie de somme
en baie du mont saint michel par exemple
pour les plus proches de chez nous et
puis quelques-uns rentrer dans les
rivières dans les fleuves la scène la
loire la garonne et remonte plus ou
moins et il y en a qui font plusieurs
centaines de kilomètres en rivière et
qui reste plusieurs semaines voire
quelques mois
notre visiteur est donc un aventurier un
curieux explorateurs dans l'âme et
viscéralement très gourmand la fois que
vient pour chasser le mulet tout
simplement et les captures sont bien
plus simples sur le milieu ligérien que
dans l'océan atlantique
et quand on parle de mulet il s'agit
bien sûr du poisson et non pas d'un
bourricot mais alors pourquoi
l'apparition somme toute charmante de
cet animal nous met dans tous nos états
pourquoi est-ce devenu un événement
pendant trois quart de siècle il n'ya
plus d'observations dans les fleuves
depuis 1900 jusqu'à 1975
résultat à chaque fois qu'a phoques
veaux marins pointe hors de l'eau le
bout de son museau
on sort le grand jeu pour que dans les
consciences on constate que c'est un
phénomène normal il faudra des années
des années et encore beaucoup
d'observation il est passé par ici il
repassera peut être par là quoi qu'il en
soit n'oubliez pas le phoque veau marin
est une espèce protégée